ich hoffe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 31
erste beratung des von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zur reform des vig
spiegel rechts für die aussprache ist
eine dauer von 30 minuten beschlossen
und nun wird also über den mietspiegel
diskutiert und über eine reform der
dazugehörigen regelungen und als erster
sprechen wird dazu die
bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht hier sehen wir schon im sie im
bild partei angehörigkeit ist die spd
und sie hat jetzt gleich fünf minuten um
diese reformen diesen gesetzentwurf hier
vorzustellen
die bundesministerin christine lambrecht
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
kollegen wohnen muss bezahlbar sein und
wohnen muss vor allen dingen bezahlbar
bleiben
das ist das credo dieser bundesregierung
und dafür haben wir vieles mittlerweile
auf den weg gebracht wir haben eine
mietpreis bremse verlängert und
verschärft mieterhöhung wegen
modernisierung haben wir enge grenzen
gezogen und außerdem werden wir noch die
umwandlung von mietwohnungen in
eigentumswohnungen stärker begrenzen und
mit dem gesetz sind gesetzt dass wir
heute beraten gehen wir den nächsten
schritt wir reformieren ein kernbereich
unseres mietrechts nämlich dass
mietspiegel recht
und warum ist das notwendig weil eben
ein wesentlicher baustein in unserem
sozialen mietrecht die sogenannte
ortsübliche vergleichsmiete ist und
diese vergleichsmiete markiert eine
grenze wenn vermieter die miete im
laufenden mietverhältnis erhöhen wollen
und auch bei der mietpreis bremse kommt
diese vergleichsmiete ins spiel
ob der vermieter nämlich bei der neu
familie
mehr verlangen darf als im alten
mietverhältnis das hängt ebenfalls von
dieser ortsüblichen vergleichsmiete ab
und klar ist deshalb mieter und
mietinteressenten müssen die
ortsüblichen vergleichsmiete einfach
zuverlässig und rechtssicher ermitteln
können
und das beste instrument hierfür sind
qualifizierte mietspiegel also solche
die nach wissenschaftlichen grundsätzen
erstellt werden
leider scheuen viele kommunen bislang
den aufwand für die erstellung solcher
mietspiegel und dort wo qualifizierte
mietspiegel existieren gibt es oft
streit um sie mit unserem gesetz und
einer begleitenden rechtsverordnung
schaffen wir jetzt da abhilfe
wir erleichtern die erstellung von
qualifizierten mietspiegel und wir
steigern deren qualität und transparenz
denn erstmals schreiben wir präzise fest
welche standards bei der erstellung von
qualifizierten mietspiegel beachtet
werden müssen und zugleich stellen wir
klar um einen qualifizierten mietspiegel
zu erstellen
reicht es im regelfall auch aus genau
diese definierten standards einzuhalten
und damit ist gewährleistet dass sie im
streitfall auch von den gerichten
akzeptiert werden
mit unserem gesetz erleichtern wir
außerdem den zugriff auf vorhandene
datensätze bei der erstellung von
mietspiegeln und wir begründen
auskunftspflichten auch damit machen wir
die erstellung von mietspiegeln
einfacher und verbessern ihre qualität
für mehr transparenz und bessere
nachvollziehbarkeit schreiben wir über
die ess fest mietspiegel und auch die
zugrunde liegende dokumentationen müssen
immer frei verfügbar im internet sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mietspiegel mietpreis bremse
vergleichsmieten das sind schwierige
konzepte und sie dürfen uns nicht den
blick auf das wesentliche versperren es
geht darum dass sich alle menschen ihre
wohnung leisten können
ihr zuhause es geht um einen fairen
interessenausgleich und dafür sind gute
aussagefähige mietspiegel unverzichtbar
sie schaffen klarheit darüber da darf
ruhig geklatscht werden sie schaffen
nämlich klarheit darüber was zulässig
ist und was nicht und sie verhindern
rechtsstreit und sie diene damit den
interessen von mietern und vermietern
gleichermaßen und gerade deshalb ist
unsere reform so wichtig ob derzeit
wirklich um ihre zustimmung christina
lambrecht hat hier doch recht kurz um
die zustimmung zu ihrem gesetzentwurf
geworben auf sie folgt jetzt udo
hemmelgarn erst für die fw fraktion der
sprecher für bau wohnen stadtentwicklung
und kommunen
das wort hat der abgeordnete udo
hemmelgarn für die fw fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte besucher auf den tribünen
an den bildschirm
der vorliegende gesetzentwurf zur reform
des mietspiegels rechts zeigt wieder
einmal dass die bundesregierung erstens
schwierigkeiten damit hat dem deutschen
bürger die wahl zu sagen zweiter die
umgestaltung unserer gesellschaft nach
der salamitaktik scheibchenweise
vornimmt
und drittens faktisch weitgehend rot
grüne politik betreibt
richtig ist dass der mietspiegel ein
wichtiges element ist mit recht ist und
den sozialen frieden im land geschützt
umso wichtiger wäre es allerdings hier
nicht den üblichen etikettenschwindel zu
betreiben
nach der zielstellung des gesetzentwurfs
soll die rechtssicherheit für
qualifizierte mietspiegel erhöht werden
tatsächlich beschäftigt sie ein großer
teil der neuregelung allerdings mit
verlängerung des erstellungs zeitraums
für mietspiegel von zwei auf drei oder
von 45 jahre
das lässt sich natürlich mit den
entstehenden kosten wunderbar begründen
in wirklichkeit ist es jedoch so dass
die bundesregierung wohl meint den
weiteren anstieg der mieten auf diese
art und weise dämpfen zu können mit
diesem gesetzentwurf entfernt sich der
mietspiegel immer weiter von der
aktuellen marktlage diese eigentliche
kern des gesetzes vorhaben wird nicht
offen kommuniziert
dabei ist es offensichtlich dass die
bundesregierung zu an billigen trick
greift um ihr versagen in der
wohnungspolitik zu vertuschen
wieder einmal will man strenge
regulierung ohne das problem an der
wurzel zu packen und wieder einmal sagt
man den bürgern nicht die wahrheit
von den versprochenen 105 millionen
neubauwohnungen in dieser legislatur
werden wohl nicht einmal 12 millionen
fertiggestellt in diesem sinn an diesem
versagen ändert sich auch nichts durch
700.000 wohnungen für die es
baugenehmigung gibt die aber nicht
gebaut wurden in wohnungen die dich
gebaut werden
nicht gewohnt der vorliegende
gesetzentwurf verabschiedet sich dabei
ausdrücklich von den anerkannten
wissenschaftlichen grundsätzen die
bislang für die erstellung
qualifizierter mietspiegel gelten
künftig soll stand die objektive
einhaltung wissenschaftlicher grundsätze
für einen qualifizierten mietspiegel
ausreichen
das soll angeblich der rechtssicherheit
dienen der professor thorsten des
mietrechts wird wunsch unser wald
gefunden werden
aber es geht noch weiter die
mindestvoraussetzung für einen
qualifizierten mietspiegel sollen
künftig allein durch die exekutive ohne
parlamentarische kontrolle festgelegt
werden können
auch insoweit hat man sich wohl am
konzept des geänderten
infektionsschutzgesetzes orientiert hier
wie dort arbeitet die große koalition an
entmachtung des parlaments und verlagert
elementare kompetenzen auf die regierung
jeder kann sich ausmalen wie die
mietspiegel verordnung aussehen wird
falls die grünen am härtesten
justizminister stellen
sehr geehrte damen und herren deutlicher
als durch diese art der gesetzgebung
hier kann man seine missachtung der
parlamentarischen demokratie nicht hin
zum ausdruck bringen
dieser gesetzentwurf ist nur einer von
vielen maßnahmen zu nennen wären hier
die mietpreis bremse die bürgerbegehren
zu enteignungen das umwandlungs verbot
und völlig überzogene umweltauflagen die
jede für sich genommen schon schwer
erträglich während in der gesamtheit
haben sie eine katastrophale wirkung
bleibt am ende die frage wo das ganze
hinführt soll
leider ist die antwort sehr eindeutig es
ist ein folgenschwerer gang hin in den
sozialismus worin sozialistische
allmachtsfantasien führen kann man am
berliner mieten deckel bewundern
dieses gescheiterte experiment erst
viele mieter mit hohem mieter
nachzahlungen zurück ich möchte in
diesem zusammenhang ausdrücklich hörbuch
dem vorstandsvorsitzenden der wowi ag
den größten deutschen wohnungsvermieter
danken der auf
mit nachzahlungen aus dem gestrigen
urteil zu mieten deckel verzichten würde
das wäre doch ein gutes zeichen für
andere größere wohnungsvermieter hier in
berlin die diesem beispiel folgen
sollten sehr geehrte damen und herren
die zunehmende regulierung wird dazu
führen dass sich zunächst kleinere und
dann größere privatinvestoren aus dem
wohnungsmarkt zurückziehen die nächste
krise auf dem wohnungsmarkt wird dann
wieder einmal hausgemacht seien genauso
wie die gegenwärtige vielen dank nutzen
sie bitte die maske
für die cdu csu fraktion hat nun der
kollege carsten müller das wort frau
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren die bedeutung von
mietspiegeln hat in dieser wahlperiode
außerordentlich stark zugenommen die
große koalition hat die hat sie mit
kreis bremse an geschärft und meine
damen und herren dadurch ist auch der
begriff der ortsüblichen vergleichsmiete
besonders in den fokus gerückt worden
die ortsübliche vergleichsmiete ist
heute für die gestaltung für die
preislichen gestaltung von mietverträgen
im wohnungsbereich die zentrale referenz
reichweite und auswirkungen der
mietpreis bremse hängen also
entscheidend von einer rechtssicheren
datengrundlage ab und wir wollen und das
ist unser ziel
unnötige gerichtsverfahren vermeiden
indem wir genau diese rechtssichere
datengrundlage schaffen um diese
rechtliche datengrundlage zu schaffen
brauchen wir bundeseinheitliche
kriterien wir müssen also insgesamt
bundeseinheitlich vollkommen unabhängig
wo sie in der republik der markt und wie
er sich gestaltet die auf die
vergleichbaren grundsätze abstellen
können als union haben wir bereits
parallel mit der einführung der
mietpreise eine reform der mietspiegel
regulierung gefordert
wir freuen uns dass diese jetzt
vorgelegt wird sie kommen für uns das
will ich allerdings auch deutlich sagen
allerdings etwas zu spät wir hätten uns
da mehr beschleunigung beim
bundesjustizministerium gewünscht meine
damen und herren bundesweit zeigt sich
ein höchst unterschiedliches bild bei
dem blick auf die mietspiegel die give
me spiele kommission hat weil die 200
größten städte deutschlands in den blick
genommen und hat sie zu ende 2019 und
verglichen dabei haben wir durchaus sehr
interessante feststellungen geliefert
bekommen lediglich 73 dieser
betrachteten städte und das sind
deutlich weniger als 40 prozent
erstellen einen qualifizierten
mietspiegel obwohl eben genau dieser das
sicherste die sicherste art und weise
einen mietspiegel
zu gestalten darstellt 91 steht also 46
prozent der stellen nur einen einfachen
mietspiegel und mich persönlich hat das
sehr erschreckt dass 36 städte also rund
ein fünftel der in den blick genommen
städte gar kein mietspiegel erstellt
darunter sind wiederum 15 städte mit
angespannten wohnungsmarkt
dort gibt es also keine belastbare und
sozusagen von vor nach einen streit
schlichten datensichere grund dann das
zeigt also es gibt viel zu tun ein
mietspiegel muss den tatsächlichen
mietmarkt wieder spielen und soll nicht
nur eine betrachtung in die
vergangenheit sein dass die der
gesichtspunkt der ortsüblichen
vergleichsmiete ist eben auch kein
politisches steuerungsinstrument sondern
es muss die situation am mieten markt
widerspiegeln und nicht prägen
marktmechanismen sollen durch
mietspiegel nicht ersetzt während das
wäre eine ganz konkrete zweck verfehlung
meine damen und herren wir wollen also
den mietspiegel nicht als
instrumentarium der politischen
gestaltung der politischen beeinflussung
des wohnungsmarktes verstanden wissen
ich hatte es eben schon gesagt den markt
spiegeln und nicht den markt ersetzen
wir werden das bei der beratung intensiv
im auge behalten meine damen letzter
punkt den ich durchaus auch noch nennen
will
das ist dem gesetzentwurf bisher zu
entnehmen
er sieht eine fiktion der
wissenschaftlichkeit vorfalls der
mietspiegel der ebenfalls vorgelegten
verordnung entspricht
das ist eine höchst problematische
ansatz denn nicht nur auf bei den heute
zb vor laufenden beratungen zu ganz
anderen punkten haben wir 1 festgestellt
wissenschaftlichkeit ist faktenbasiert
und wissenschaftlichkeit kann ich
fingiert werden deswegen ist das ein
punkt der in den beratungen der
unionsfraktion sehr wichtig sein wird
wir begrüßen dass künftig qualifizierte
mietspiegel nach klaren kriterien
erstellt werden sollen das steht ähnlich
das instrument des mietspiegels das
instrument des mietspiegels mit der
vergleichsgröße der ortsüblichen
vergleichsmiete ist ein zentrales
verbraucher schützendes element in der
mietrechtlichen regulierung wir wollen
das nicht aufgeweicht wissen wir wollen
dass gestärkt transparent
nachvollziehbar wissen da an werden wir
uns in den beratungen halt nicht bedanke
mich für die auflösung der für seine
fraktion unter anderem obmann im
ausschuss für recht und
verbraucherschutz ist hier in der
debatte des bundestags zum mietspiegel
reformgesetz der bundesrat muss dieser
verordnungs übrigens auch noch zustimmen
das heißt da wird es auch noch
diskussionen darüber geben
die nächste gegnerin ist katharina
willkommen für die fdp sie ist die
verbraucherschutzpolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wie jeder
spiegel soll der mietspiegel für den
betrachter die wirklichkeit abbilden
wenn man weiß was die anderen für
vergleichbare wohnungen zahlen kann ein
mieter seine miete und die mieterhöhung
überprüfen
leider braucht es zeit und geld um gute
mietspiegel zu erstellen
es ist daher zu begrüßen dass mit diesem
gesetz den behörden der datenaustausch
zur vorbereitung der mietspiegel
erhebung vereinfacht wird
aber ansonsten ist es ein
bürokratiemonster
unverändert wird auch zu wenigen
stichproben durch aufwändigen
statistischen hokuspokus vermeintlich
repräsentativ und repräsentativer
mietspiegel destilliert nehmen wir als
beispiel berlin hier leben die menschen
zu 80 prozent in mietwohnungen auf einer
bebauten fläche von rund 490
quadratkilometer
für den qualifizierten mietspiegel soll
3000 stichproben ausreichen eine
stichprobe repräsentiert damit 163 1000
quadratmetern oder auch 23 fußballfelder
als fdp-fraktion haben wir bereits vor
über einem jahr die lösung gezeigt
anstatt die mieter mit aufwändigen
umfrage doppelte zu erich leben nutzen
wir doch gleich die finanzämter die
canon aus der steuererklärung der
vermieter jedes mietverhältnis in der
republik
diese daten diese daten können dann
nämlich verlässlich anonymisiert werden
und dann an die gemeinden weitergeleitet
werden anstatt sich mit vermutungen zu
begnügen stünde der mietspiegel damit
auf einer breiten datenbasis zudem
können sich dadurch auch kleine kommunen
einen qualifizierten mietspiegel leisten
war die teure datenerhebung entsteht
leider verhindern sie aber mit anderen
vorgaben dass der mietspiegel wirklich
nicht wirklich positiv sein kann denn
sie haben erst 2020 dem zeitraum einer
einzubeziehen mieten auf die
abgelaufenen sechs jahren ausgeweitet
und mit diesem gesetz wollen sie das
verfallsdatum des mietspiegels einer oft
drei jahre verlängern sie entkoppeln dem
mietspiegel bewusst immer mehr von der
realität weil ihnen nicht gefällt was
ein aktueller mietspiegel ihnen zeit
explodierende mieten in den großstädten
gleichzeitig fallen auf dem platten land
die mieteinnahmen um mit ihnen verfallen
die häuser die lebensverhältnisse
zwischen stadt und land driften immer
weiter auseinander
das liegt nicht nur ihrem versagen und
internetausbau beim öpnv aus verbänden
vielen jobs dies treibt immer mehr
menschen vom land in die stadt
das macht den wohnraum knapper und was
knapp ist teuer
diese einfache wahrheit können sie nicht
weg regulieren deshalb da
ihre mietpreis bremse und deshalb auch
der rot-grüne mieten decke keine lösung
die mietpreise werden sich erst stabel
dieser welt genug wohnungen vorhanden
sind wir brauchen mehr niveau und eine
werde zur ein klima nation wir müssen
bauern bauen bauen auf katharina
willkommen folgt jetzt karin leises für
die linksfraktion die sprecherin für
mieten bau und wohnungspolitik das wort
die kollegin karin neue für die fraktion
gelingt frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ja es würde
wirklich höchste zeit dass die
mietspiegel endlich länger gelten und
dass sie endlich recht sicher gemacht
werden denn so hofft er die nägel von
den konzernen angegriffen und vor
gericht gekippt gerade die großen
wohnungs konzerne wie etwa deutsche
wohnen verweisen da beispielsweise gerne
auf vergleichswohnungen um die
mietspiegel zu umgehen und deswegen
hatten wir unser ursprung nicht nur vor
dass im referentenentwurf dieses
beliebte schlupfloch endlich geschlossen
werden sollte und nur noch qualifizierte
mietspiegel als maßstab gelten auch das
ursprünglich vorgesehen dass der
mietspiegel als wissenschaftlich
anerkennt werden eindeutig als
wissenschaft anerkannt werden sollten
haben wir begrüßt aber nein
im vorgelegten gesetzesentwurf sind
beide schlupflöcher wieder enthalten da
hat die lobby wieder ganze arbeit
gemacht
im ergebnis werden die ohnehin recht
wirkungslosen mietspiegel wieder vor
gericht landen
meine damen und herren
es genau dieses not lose runde buchse
was die mieterinnen und mieter in diesem
land nicht verdient haben
die vorgelegte mietspiegel reform ist
angesichts der großen herausforderungen
wirklich ein schlechter witz und ich
will daran erinnern dass es in der
amtszeit dieser koalition in jetzt fast
acht jahren die mieten im gesamten
bundesgebiet explodiert sind fünf
prozent höhere mieten allein in einem
einzigen jahr
das ist ihre verantwortung und der sind
sie bis heute nicht gerecht geworden
aber dann hat sie ja noch ein tropfen
setzt und das würde ich heute schon
nochmal erwähnen am heutigen tag
denn gestern hat er das
verfassungsgericht in karlsruhe den
berliner mietspiegel gekippt das einzige
gesetz in der ganzen republik was
wirkungsvoll die mieten begrenzt hätte
und die union und die fdp sind
verfassungsgericht gezogen und
gleichzeitig legen sie heute wieder
irgendwie so ein gurk sowas halbherziges
vor
das zeigt den unterschied zwischen einer
wirklich angehörten mietenpolitik und
einer alibi politik ist für die schöne
stelle schon noch mal sagen und tun sie
doch nicht so als würde es ihnen hier
und geburt durch zuständigkeit gehen
herr luczak wo ich sie auch gerade sehe
ihnen ging es doch tatsächlich nur darum
dass sie mieten explosion weitergehen
kann und dass ihre babys aus der in gold
immobilien lobby weiter kassieren können
das ist doch die wahrheit als dass es
sicherlich kein zufall dass im gleichen
jahr wo sie vors verfassungsgericht
gegangen sind
die union 1,2 millionen spenden aus der
immobilienwirtschaft erhalten hat und
auf konter
und spendete alleine der bau nur für
christoph grüne an die cdu berlin bei
den damen und herren das ist doch
harmlos aber beide können sich sicher
sein wir werden uns von diesem urteil
nicht ermutigen lassen wenn es das land
berlin nicht machen kann dann machen wir
es auf bundesebene
wir kämpfen für einen bundesweiten
mieten deckel und eines weiß ich das
geht nur ohne die union die union
raus aus der regierung so schnell wie
möglich nur so kriegen wir sind mit
einem bundesweiten mieten deckel
vielen dank für die fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen hat nun der kollege chris
kühn das wort
[Applaus]
ja frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen
kollegen auch ich hätte mir das will ich
auch richtung unionsfraktion sagen herr
gestern mehr demut gewünscht ja bei dem
bei dem entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts denn gestern
ist ja nicht entschieden worden dass der
mieten deckel in berlin inhaltlich nicht
verfassungsgemäß ist sondern in seiner
form und das muss man schon in dieser an
diesem tag und an diesem parlament noch
einmal festhalten
er ist in seiner form nicht
verfassungsgemäß weil dem land berlin
einfach die kompetenz nicht zusteht ist
zu erlassen und deswegen liegt der
spielball bei der frage wie wir in
zukunft mit den mieten und der sozialen
krise in unseren städten angestiegen
angesichts dieser gestiegenen mieten
umgehen ganz klar hier im deutschen
bundestag und ich sage ihnen eins wir
müssen die frage der steigenden mieten
in diesem parlament lösen das ist unsere
verantwortung das
bundesverfassungsgericht war gestern
ganz klar ja der gesetzgeber ist frei
hier sozial politische erwägungen zu
ziehen
so und jetzt ziehen wir hier
unterschiedliche und die union hat eben
in den letzten jahren gezeigt dass sie
mir keine sozialpolitischen erwägung
ziehen sondern der lobby hinterherrennen
ja ein vernünftiges mietrecht blockieren
ja und sie blockieren eben auch heute
hier bei der mietspiegel reform wieder
weitreichende maßnahmen so ist es doch
so wir sprechen heute über die
ortsübliche vergleichsmiete und die
ortsübliche vergleichsmiete ist einfach
nicht trivial denn sie ist der fixpunkt
an die mieterhöhung in deutschland
möglich sind und deswegen ist dieser
reform und das was sie heute hier
vorlegen ganz klar ja ganz klar viel zu
wenig um die mieten in den städten zu
bremsen es ist eine vertane chance für
die mieterinnen und mieter in
deutschland für den sozialen
zusammenhalt in deutschland und es
möchte ich ganz klar an drei punkten an
drei punkten einfach ausführen
das erste ist der betrachtungszeitraum
der mietspiegel ist einfach nach wie vor
zu gering
die ausweitung von vier auf sechs jahren
doch nicht aus ich meine man kann sagen
dass die mietspiegel heute neu vertrags
mit spiegel sind aber sie biss hingegen
keine mietspiegel weil sie nicht die
mieten in der breite abbilden
wir brauchen ihre form das ist doch
vollkommen klar
22 die mieterhöhung möglichkeiten ja vom
referentenentwurf zum kabinettsentwurf
hat sich das ja noch mal dramatisch
geändert denn die drei vergleichsmieten
sind wieder reingekommen
damit schaffen sie ein schlupfloch bei
den mitspielern damit untergraben sie
die wissenschaftlichen mietspiegel
selbst noch mal das verstehen wir nicht
und hier hätten wir uns mehr mut
gewünscht ja mehr mut gewünscht dieses
instrument wirklich vom
referentenentwurf über den
kabinettsentwurf zu retten und ich hoffe
dass wir hier im parlamentarischen
verfahren das noch mal anders gestalten
können und das dritte ist es wäre die
chance gewesen es wäre die chance
gewesen auch für die spd er aber für die
gesamte große koalition einfach jetzt
die lehre aus dem gestrigen tag zu
ziehen und die kappungsgrenzen in
deutschland noch mal deutlich abzusenken
denn wer es ist doch genau das
instrument es wirken soll in den
gebieten in denen wir wohnraummangel
haben um die bestandsmieten und den
anstieg der bestandsmieten zu bremsen
hier fehlt ihnen die kraft ich kann nur
sagen wir grüne werden dieses thema in
diesem jahr thematisieren und wir werden
es zu einer wichtigen frage in diesem
bundestagswahlkampf machen
denn eins ist klar der mieten waren sind
in unseren städten muss gestoppt werden
denn sonst ist unser zusammenhalt
bedroht dankeschön so weit der sprecher
für bau und wohnungspolitik der
grünen-fraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag und die vorletzte rednerin in
dieser debatte ist mechthild rawert sie
sitzt für die spd fraktion im ausschuss
für recht und verbraucherschutz und
das hier ist ja erst die erste debatte
die erste beratung zum gesetzentwurf
danach wird der gesetzentwurf in die
entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen
kollegen liebe zu hören und wie vorhin
gelernt habe liebe bildschirm sehen
frau bundesministerin nachgereicht hat
die reform unter fallenden die ziele der
mietspiegel rechts reform also schon
sehr genau beschrieben daher nur an
dieser stelle ein punkt darauf seitens
der grünen gerade schon hingewiesen
worden ja wir sozialdemokraten werden
licht eine wichtige änderung noch
erstreiten müssen nämlich das
schlupfloch der vergleichswohnungen
tatsächlich zu streichen
wir wollen dieses einfallstor zur
umgehung der ortsüblichen
vergleichsmiete nicht dafür wie gesagt
kämpfen wir im rahmen des
parlamentarischen verfahrens ein wort zu
gestern der berliner mieten deckel ist
gekippt das haben wir zur kenntnis zu
nehmen aber das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat nicht darüber entschieden ob
anmieten decke zulässig ist sondern
höchstens wer diesen bieten deckel
erlassen darf und niemand aus laufen
gleich den widerstand der union hindert
uns als bundesgesetzgeber das mietrecht
sozialverträglich auch an dieser stelle
weiter vor zu entwickeln
wir als bundestagsabgeordnete sind
aufgefordert so schnell wie möglich ein
entsprechendes bundesgesetz zu
erarbeiten
und ich sage auch deutlich wir als spd
wollen dieses andere progressive
politische parteien wollen es auch
und zwar um auch unter anderem einfach
um den verpflichtungen insbesondere mit
den großen lobbyisten der
immobilienwirtschaft zu widerstehen
wir wollen bestehen des bundes rechnung
einen verfassungsgemäßen mieten stoppen
angespannten wohnungsmärkten gerade in
großstädten und ballungsräumen ergänzen
wir fordern schon lange anmieten
moratorium im bundesgesetz um mietwucher
also wirksam zu unterbinden
wir wollen die mietpreis bremse
entfristen und schlupflöcher schließen
wir wollen den betrachtungszeitraum von
mietspiegeln auf acht jahre verlängern
und vor allen dingen wollen wir noch
eines und das in dieser legislatur wir
wollen mit dem bauland
modernisierungsgesetz kommunen bei der
schaffung von bezahlbarem wohnraum in
innenstadtlagen und bei der ausübung von
vorkommens rechten und bauen boten
stärken
das schützt auch mieterinnen und mieter
vor der verdrängung in dem wir nämlich
die umwandlung von mietwohnungen in
eigentumswohnungen erschweren meist sind
winter sowieso nur spekulative
finanzgeschäfte mit anderen worten mit
uns ist aktive und eine
sozialverträgliche mieten politik zu
machen
und eines ist klar das was wir in dieser
legislatur nicht mehr schaffen werden
wir deutlich im wahlkampf herausstellen
wir kämpfen für eine bundeseinheitliche
verfassungsreform eine
verfassungskonforme regelung für den
mieten deckel lassen sie uns das
gemeinsam tun auch mit dem kurs bei der
spd bei der bundestagswahl am 26.9
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion hat nun jan
marco luczak das wort frau präsidentin
meine sehr verehrten kollegen und
kolleginnen eigentlich reden wir jetzt
ja über die mietspiegel aber nachdem nun
alle redner auf das gestrige urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes eingegangen
ist zum mieten decke glaube ich muss ich
da doch noch mal ein paar dinge
klarstellen an der stelle
sowohl die grünen als auch die linken
als auch unser koalitionspartner die spd
verwundert ich auch nicht sie habe mit
den bieten becker gemeinsam in berlin
auf den weg gebracht sagen jetzt tun wir
brauchen einen bundesweiten bieten
deckel
da muss ich da muss ich mich doch schon
sehr wundern da muss ich mich doch schon
sehr wundern wenn sie sich mal die
entscheidung in karlsruhe anschauen die
war erst mal in ihrer klarheit nicht zu
überbieten ist war eine einstimmige
entscheidung acht zu null
die gesagt hat das land berlin hat für
einen solchen mieten decke keine
kompetenz und das war ein
verfassungsbruch mit ansage den der rot
rot grüne senat in berlin gemacht hat
alle experten haben gesagt das geht
nicht und sie haben sie haben ihre
ideologische verbohrtheit auf den rücken
der berlinerinnen und berliner
ausgetragen weil die berliner mieter
nämlich am ende die leidtragenden
gewesen sind gucken sie sich doch mal an
was der mieten decke in berlin wirklich
bewirkt hat was hat denn den medien
erwägt becker bewirkt zwei jahre ist
hier in berlin nichts passiert zwei
jahre ist nichts passiert mit der mit
dem beginn der diskussion um den mieten
decke haben all diejenigen die gesagt
haben ich möchte im land berlin
investieren ich möchte hier neue
wohnungen schaffen ich möchte
altersgerecht umgebaute wohnraum
schaffen ich möchte für den klimaschutz
etwas machen um hier zum beispiel
energetische modernisierung vereinbart
da ist nichts mehr passiert weil alle
gesagt habe unter den bedingungen des
mieten decke funktioniert das nicht mehr
ist das nicht mehr wirtschaftlich
tragbar
und was ist für die berliner mieter
dennoch passiert das an
gebot an neuen mietwohnungen wenn sich
die fatale eindruck ist dramatisch
eingebrochen um mehr als 50 prozent sind
die angebote an wohnung zurückkehren was
ist die folge gewesen
die schlangen bei der
wohnungsbesichtigung die sind noch
länger geworden es war noch nie so
schwierig in berlin eine wohnung zu
finden wie oder dem geltung des
picknicks und das wollen sie jetzt als
vorbild für den bund machen das kann
davor den eigentlichen amtszeit vom
menschen jetzt auch noch sagen da ja das
sei ja nur eine formale entscheidung
gewesen ja richtig selbstverständlich
das bundesverfassungsgericht der zweite
senat weil es der staatsorganisation
senat ist hat über die frage der
zuständigkeiten entschieden das ist
richtig und er hat weil das üblich so
ist nicht in eine mobile diktum etwas zu
den materiell rechtlichen fragen
ausgeführt da kann man aber sehr
trefflich darüber streiten ob unter dem
blickwinkel dass artikel 14
unter dem blickwinkel des artikel 12
unter dem blickwinkel auch das artikel 3
eine solche regelung zulässig wäre
ich habe da meine großen zweifel ob das
ist ich will nur mal ein beispiel mit
artikel 3
wir reden ja am ende auch über
verhältnismäßigkeit fragen ist so etwas
geeignet ist so etwas erforderlich ist
es am ende angemessen wenn sie sich die
auswirkung das mieten beck ist
anscheinend ein party schon genannt aber
wenn sie auch die soziale
steuerungswirkung dieses miesenböck es
sich anschauen wer hat denn vermieten
deckel eigentlich profitiert wer hat
denn profitiert die mieten sind doch am
stärksten gesunken
abgesenkt worden vom gesetzgeber in den
job sanierten altbau wurden am kudamm
dort wo die gutverdienenden zahnärztlich
spitze ist mal zu wurden die haben davon
profitiert die haben vorher 17 18 und 19
20 euro miete zahlt sie konnten es sich
leisten
jetzt haben sie am ende nur noch zehn
euro bezahlt und diejenigen die in
marzahn wohnen denen es wirtschaftlich
wirklich nicht so gut geht die haben von
diesen mieten deckel noch überhaupt
nichts gehabt das ist noch eine
schreiende soziale und
ich weiß was sie da auf den weg gebracht
haben das können wir mit vorbildlichen
und klein
meine damen und herren vor uns als union
ist ganz klar wir wollen starke soziale
leitplanken im mietrecht haben und die
haben wir als bundesgesetzgeber auf den
weg gebracht deswegen kann ich auch
unsere koalitionspartner die spd an
dieser stelle nicht verstehen wir haben
in dieser legislaturperiode so viele
dinge auf den weg gebracht die lied
price bremse
wir haben den mietpreis bremse verstarb
wir haben da den modernisierungs
mieterhöhung dort muss wirklich zur
deutlichen mietsteigerungen kommen ist
dann wer die umlage fähigkeit von elf
auf acht prozent reduziert und sie haben
sie vor allem gedeckelt das ist ein
wirklich eine wirkliche richtig starke
soziale leitplanke die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben wir sollten doch unsere
erfolge die wir gemeinsam als koalition
erreicht haben sich immer nur klein
reden sondern wir haben richtig was
gemacht für die mieterinnen und mieter
in dieser legislaturperiode und deswegen
und deswegen würde ich mir wünschen weil
die menschen dort draußen ja auch
wirklich zum teil angst haben zum teil
angst haben dass sie ihre wohnung
verlieren das sie gekündigt bekommen
dass die mieten zu stark steigt und
deswegen würde ich uns alle ermuntern
wollen lassen sie uns nicht mit der
angst der menschen spielen lassen sie
uns nicht mit der angst der menschen
wahlkampf machen sondern machen wir
ihnen mut dass das gesetzliche
instrumentarium was wir haben was
nochmal starke soziale leitplanken für
die mieterinnen und mieter in unseren
städten bedeutet dass sie das auch
nutzen die metronom da draußen die sind
gut geschützt und dafür steht auch die
union und das wollen wir und deswegen
keinen wahlkampf mit der angst der
menschen vor steigenden mieten
soweit also die debatte zum
mietenspiegel reformgesetz und auch wenn
jetzt hier zum schluss doch die bitte
kam kein wahlkampf damit zu machen bzw
mit der angst der menschen vor
steigenden mieten kann man davon
ausgehen dass das thema mieten auch im
wahlkampf eine rolle spielen wird unter
anderem weil das gericht ja nicht
grundsätzlich die möglichkeit einer
deutschlandweiten regelung abgelehnt hat
sondern eben nur in diesem fall die
zuständigkeit also von daher können wir
davon ausgehen dass das im wahlkampf ein
thema sein wird